going from Julia to Julian Julian says
do you think that children born today
will have better or worse lives than
their parents I just read an article
about how Millennials of which I a group
I'm a member of as we've now made it
abundantly clear may be a group that in
total has lower earnings than their
parents and typically typically each
subsequent generation earns more than
their parents and Millennials may be the
first generation since we've been
tracking this type of information that
actually has lower earnings and their
parents horse earnings alone don't tell
us about being better off or worse off
I'm reading a really good book right now
called the Great Escape by Nobel Prize
winner Angus Deaton about the escape
from abject poverty and incredibly high
infant mortality and low life expectancy
etc and there's a lot that goes into
determining whether someone is well off
or not well-off but there are real
concerns and this is why I said this
sort of relates to the Donald Trump
administration if you don't have access
to health care because of the increased
inequality income polarization and lack
of access to care due to the destruction
of social programs gutting Medicare
getting rid of the Affordable Care Act
it's more difficult to have a better
life than your parents and this goes to
our elected officials who we vote for
matters and I am NOT confident saying
that people being born now are
necessarily going to have better lives
than their parents I don't know that for
a while you could pretty safely say that
and I don't know that you can safely say
that now my hope that aside is that
because of advances when it comes to
medicine science technology that'll be
able to bypass some of those other
concerns and life expectancy will
continue to grow sure and as life
expectancy grows I think that means that
people are aging slower are healthier
for the most part but we've even seen
that life expectancy isn't taking up at
the same rate that it was before it's
not that's one of the indicators that
would show whether or not people are
going to be better off or worse off than
their parents although we have to splice
those numbers sometimes and the reason
why so when we had a lot of people dying
from communicable diseases before age
five that lowers the life
didn't see at Birth significantly right
if 15% of kids die before age five life
expectancy at birth is going to be very
low because so many people don't even
make it to age five when you solve
infant death you are going to
significantly raise longevity life
expectancy but then when you start
treating conditions that affect people
later in life like cancer cardiovascular
disease etc by improving treatments to
those conditions you're saving people
from dying that are already older
meaning you're adding fewer years to
their lives so just looking at the life
expectancy curve can be a little bit
deceptive but the other aspect of that
is you have to look at what treatments
for really you know communicable
diseases that affect kids in many cases
and infant mortality those treatments
are often very very cheap the treatments
for the later in life non communicable
diseases are much more expensive
treatment so it's also really important
to look at whether there is an income
split what is the life expectancy of the
rich versus the poor here in Boston you
have two neighborhoods Back Bay and
Roxbury which are only three miles apart
that have hugely different life
expectancy and it's really an income and
access to care thing so I think you also
have to be looking at the details when
you're looking at life expectancy we
sort of got off track here into into
account of other things however I am not
convinced that children born today will
have better lives than their parents and
the political decisions that we make are
gonna play a major role in that and I
know there's many people in our audience
who are convinced that children born
today will definitely have worse lives
in spite of advances in medicine and
advances in technology I hope that
that's not the case I mean I think it
really depends on the issue if you're
talking about cost of living and maybe
life expectancy maybe those things
aren't as exponentially tend to grow as
much as we would hope to right but I
would just hope that our advances in
science and technology don't plateau
anytime soon and that we were able to
continue this process if you believe
futurists like Ray Kurzweil he believes
that we ran in an acceleration a steep
acceleration of development
not everybody agrees with reycarts while
very very good question from Julian